so we were talking about your treatment
at the hands let's say of Western
feminists and and like I read infidel I
don't know very shortly after you
published it which and I loved that book
man as soon as I read that I thought
well I you know use which book which
book I wish the hell infidel yeah yeah
yeah you know I thought it was
remarkable I thought your comment or
your comments on viewing Western culture
from the perspective of an immigrant
that was hungry for genuine education
and and your comments on your your
experience with the efficiency of the
Dutch state say and you're sort of
amazement at how well it worked that was
just I thought that was so remarkable
and clear-headed and I thought when I
read infidel I thought well look this
woman is immediately going to be a hero
to feminists everywhere because she's
removed herself from this oppressive
state and moved out into the world and
become a powerful figure when what was
the probability of that it was like zero
you know and then you suffered as a
consequence of your beliefs and and you
stood up forthrightly for them and I
thought if you wanted to find a feminist
hero that you're certainly you're you're
certainly in the running man for exactly
that and then to see how you've been
treated this is just I just it just
makes my jaw drop you know that you're
dis what Brandeis did it was Brandeis
right where you were offered an honorary
PhD and then they revoked it that just
that was one of the I think that was
almost as reprehensible an act of
cowardice as the the West's basic
abandonment of Salman Rushdie after the
fatwa was put on his head and about
equally dangerous so I it was
multicultural I mean what I you know my
message my life story who I am it's a
defiance of the prevalent trends of
today
it's against relativism I believe that
Western values are superior to Islamic
law and Islamic values now to say that
is to blaspheme in the temples of
multiculturalism today right answer I
think I hope hooted a lot of people
because it wasn't about what they think
should happen for victims of misogyny I
think it's all about this
that my words and my my life and my
beliefs the kind of dissonance they put
these women in because if you're going
or I'm saying
well it's horrible to be an American
woman and Minnesotan in America is worse
than that in Afghanistan and I can't
rather I say no it's not right you know
I I'm interfering with their with their
well-being the claim that you're making
there is something like this and it's
really it's a really vicious claim in a
sense and it's something like the
Western feminists who are possessed by
post-modernism and cultural relativism
yeah are willing to sacrifice the
freedom and equality of third world
women in places like Saudi Arabia to
maintain the sanctity of their
multicultural notion because that
justifies their attack on Western
patriarchy so they're willing to use
okay so that that's an absolute
immigration there are so many immigrant
men who are coming from these societies
that are as men that they are not used
to the Equality of women you know they
have women inside the West first of all
there are women child marriages female
genital mutilation honor killings but
now we have these creates sexual
harassment of non-muslim women and these
women keep on arguing for more
integration yeah anything anything
negative about some of the negative
impacts of immigration I don't consider
them feminists anymore I think that
there's so much more committed to
preserving their worldview their
postmodernist value than they are to the
rights of women and and I think well
that's what it says I mean I think
that's how it looks to me is like the
situation with Saudi Arabia's the one is
the test case it's like so you might say
are the postmodern feminist types are
the ones who present themselves as that
are they more concerned with the rights
of women or they are more concerned with
bringing down the so called tyranny of
the West and the answer is they're more
concerned with the ladder than they are
with the former because when you put
them head-to-head there has dispensed
with the rights of women across the
world as long as they can maintain their
moral
for the radical police and I do think
that is why they go after you because
you're you're exactly the reprehensible
exemplar of what it is that they're
attempting to deny I would say and I
think that it does show their true
motivations absolutely in German we're
out of time I'm getting a lot of signals
here that I should I should hang up now
but I really enjoyed talking to you and
I hope that in some way I've contributed
to to the message that you want to get
out there well you know 30 seconds I'll
just tell you what what I'm doing with
this I mean I have arranged with a group
of moderate Muslims in Canada and some
in the US as well to start a series of
dialogues like the one that we had today
because this is a really viciously
important problem and so I want to use
this as the opener for that I would like
to go after this issue of whether or not
a real dialogue be begun between the
judeo-christian West and and the Islam
world with some hope of not having all
of this devolve into endless and
continual warfare because as far as I
can tell that's where it's headed
yes that's what it's headed yeah well
could get a chance to talk again thank
you so do i okay cute okay right there
yeah